okay let me first thank the organizers
for having the great sense of organizing
this workshop in in sunny California
while it's raining dogs and cats in
lausanne so it's a pleasure to be here
and for many other reasons too good so I
picked this talk because actually last
year ago quite a few of us were here at
Sammy's Institute for a while the
scientist and his student santosh that's
my name is Cody car and macro mode alien
aaron says anand we were actually all
here and it turned out that actually two
groups worked on the same problem I'm a
son toshin myself with these people here
and we actually arrived at the same
result so we put it together and so
that's what I'm presenting is not the
joint work which was done last year the
Science Institute where we'll be here
for for a couple of months good now what
I'm talking about this is coding and the
very standard setup so just since the
first talk on this I have simply some
some source and I'm thinking here of
just bits I adeeb it's and I'm making it
what's called a block hold out of this
I'm making vectors of length and out of
this is and I send it over channel and
this channel X just bitwise so the
simplest possible channel can you have
and I don't leave the channel might flip
certain bits or it might simply and
that's what we mostly going to talk
about it might hide certain bits which
is called the binary erasure channel and
at the receiver we see this perturbed
block let's call it Y and the you know
the task of course of the receiver is to
figure out with high probability what
was actually sent so we have the code
word it's perturbed and the task is to
to recover it with high probability and
so typically our setup is that we're
thinking of block code so these are n
tuples and you know this might be the
code is a very simple trivial example of
course and our task will be to do this
with high probability now in
communications really all we care is
about this particular figure so let me
just try to explain it so we have
typically not just one family one sorry
not just one channel but we have a
family of
so example in this case it's the family
of planning ratio channels where this
parameter on the horizontal axis is the
ratio probability so few oratius so you
know for example in this case 35 roughly
thirty five percent of the bits will be
hidden from you versus here about fifty
five percent will be hidden and so today
we think of having hear some good
channel and progressively as we go to
the right near the bat channel and then
for a particular code what we worry
about is really the probability of error
so how often you know what's the
probability that we actually can recover
and are too kind of versions either we
worry about recovering the whole block
or we worry about recovering the whole
bit and i'll talk about both of them and
so then the typical scenario is that we
have one other parameter maybe that's
the block length here and so this when
you look at these curves these are the
curse for various block lengths let's
say maybe you know five hundred a
thousand to thousands etc and if we're
talking about a good family of codes
then what should be true is that these
curves should approximate a jump here so
there should be a phase transition here
and this point should be exactly you
know it's a specific point which is only
to do with the rate of the code and
that's the Shannon capacity so we know
that if I want to transmit reliably over
a particular family of channels and I
want to do this let's say at half a bit
per you know have a bit of information
per bit that I'm sending then depending
on on this channel here there will be a
parameter here which tells me that below
this I can do it the assistance they can
do it but above this above the Shannon
limit I cannot do it there's no cook and
hope is of course to construct codes
which approach that as a function of N
and do so efficiently at low complexity
now traditionally if you look at all you
know your cell phones your your discs
etc and you look in there then what's in
there is typically these kind of codes
and these are codes on graphs which you
know fits very well into the picture
that we have been talking about so
instead of thinking here let's say
you've talked about k7 we have talked
about the factor graph it's very similar
for us a code would be described so
these are the bits of the code in this
case it's a trivial case it's like just
three bits that define the code in
practice this would be a thousand or ten
thousand
a million and then the code is defined
by adding certain constraints to it so
in in in case that's there's certain
constraints for us these are typically
linear constraints such as X ores and
the coil is defined is the set of all
these bits you know vectors of length n
that fulfill these linear constraints so
in this case I've really great the
freedoms of to start with I take away
two degrees of freedom because have two
linear constraints so they're really to
one degree of freedom in here so there's
really just two code words that in in
general that would that would define the
code and the standard picture and that
again fits very well with you know what
many people already have talked about is
the standard decoding is what Gallagher
had introduced them a message passing ok
so you you start with the receive think
so for example here it's for the erasure
channel we're starting with a certain
bit sequence but some of them are erased
and then we're sending back and forth by
message passing these messages using the
local constraints in a greedy fashion
and hope that we actually converge to
there to the right limit ok so these are
the codes and graphs they're known as
either low-density parity-check codes to
a book codes many other classes codes
and that's pretty much what you have in
any in any real system that you really
have read no question raise your code in
an erasure channel when you've lost a
bit you know that this is missing or yes
so right so that you know the two kind
of or the three most important channel
models is the ratio model in which if
you lost it then you indeed you don't
just get zeros in once but it gets here
in one and a question mark and there
there's some physical property that
tells you you know something went wrong
in the in the binary symmetric channel
it simply gets flipped but you don't
know you might know the probability of
flipping that you don't know where and
additive white Gaussian noise channels
in which you get a real number plus some
some Gaussian noise ok so these are the
three most important models and then
many of the more complicated is real
models that just build up you know by
making kind of combinations of these
things and so on but if you understand
these three you understand pretty much
the picture so codes on graphs fit very
well into this it fits you know how do
you analyze these things we already had
several talks about this tool well if
you do message passing for quotes it's
relatively simple Andrea had talked
about
the density evolution and if you analyze
dance evolution for this course and this
tells you exactly what and the message
passing you can do and then you can also
ask for the ground street is and that's
what actually optimum recording but do
it as we have heard now in many other
talks that's typically also a gap
meaning if you take such a type of code
you know there would be something that
you can do efficiently on a message
passing and there's something that you
can do if you had optimal decoding maybe
you know map decoding and then there's a
third limit which is the absolute limit
the Shannon limit and the hope is that
with the efficient algorithm you get as
close as possible to this shannon limit
so that's the name of the game okay so
as I said that's pretty much the
standard that everyone is using but
that's not what I want to talk today so
the history is kind of interesting in
the in 48 when she not defined capacity
you know there were not really any
quotes around but then very soon they
were quotes defined nummy reed-muller
codes reed-solomon codes bch codes and
they were very nice in that they have a
lot of structures a lot of algebraic
structure and tell you a little bit
about it so it's the opposite of random
and you know these were beautiful codes
that have many nice properties and they
were used for some space exploration and
so on but they don't get you very close
to capacity at least with the decoding
algorithms that people knew at the time
and so then over time other class of
course came along so in particular you
know low density parity charge at your
codes and now we have also things like
polar codes etc and so these codes kind
of were forgotten okay and people really
didn't talk so much about but as it
often happens in in history and history
repeats itself and as I'll try to tell
you now that these quotes actually
coming back with a vengeance and become
again very interesting because of some
new developments so what are these codes
so this is this is mother and this is
read and in 54 I think they you know
first redefined the codes and then as a
sort first molar they find the codes and
then read I found a decoding algorithm
and they were quite popular in the 50s
if you look at typical text books in the
60s and 70s the whole chapters dedicated
to these kind of coats because they're
very lots of
symmetries and nice properties and I
tell you a little bit about what this
properties were so now they were as I
said pretty much forgotten and for a
while and there were only a few people
that were worked on it this is ilya duma
who you know for the last you know 10 or
15 years consistently still worked on
this kind of course but you know it was
not a particularly hot topic i dint in
communications or in computer science
for for quite for quite a while now why
are people now back interested at these
quotes because in 2008 there was another
class of course they find which are
called polar quotes and it turns out
that polar quotes are the first class of
codes for which we can prove that their
capacity achieving under low complexity
cooling eyewitness and although density
parity check codes and so on before we
are known to be very good but there was
like a proof missing it's only very
lately that we have actually found a
proof for that and so you know they have
many many nice properties vary you know
universal lots of applications so they
were quite you know stirred quite some
interest even for current you know next
generous wireless systems and it turns
out that these codes are actually very
related to regular codes and so since
now you know people discuss the polar
holds are very good you know people try
to go back and say hmm maybe read middle
codes in fact in the 50s we are also
excellent maybe we just didn't know
about it so let me just tell you a
little bit what the connection between
these two types of courses so look at
this matrix here so this thing here just
represents in in this case eight by
eight binary matrix and you know it's
just you just think of it that you're
put in here zeros and ones and you send
it forward when you ever have a note
like this simply both of these you know
it sends the message forward both of
them and you have something like this
then this is simply the XOR okay so this
is just a matrix multiplication with
whatever vector you you have and so
think of this is the information and
think of this is the code word here okay
now it turns out that this is an N by n
invertible matrix so that itself doesn't
form a code because it would have rate
one there's no redundancy put in here
but it turns out that he can do the
following at the decoder you do the
following this is the chat
and so each of them goes for an
independent channel you observe the
observation why here and you do what's
called successive decoding so you try to
figure out what u 0 is given the whole
observation here and assuming that you
know nothing about these so these are
simply I I deep it's okay and that turns
out if you if you untangled it a little
bit that if you look at what this is
this is simply a tree you know an
inference problem on a tree and so
message passing is optimum so you can
just simply send the messages up there
and you get some probability of error
for this bit okay so let's assume you
could actually do this so imagine this
again not eight by eight but let's say a
thousand five thousand matrix and so
let's assume you could figure out what
this bit here is then you go simply to
the next bit okay so next bit is here
you want this particular order assuming
that you already have you 0 and again it
turns out that this is simply the co
inference problem on a tree you can do
this efficiently and you simply go down
you know as in a certain order now yes
little notes or X ores here is released
these notes attic sores these ones and
these are simply repetition so you
simply repeat whatever you have and you
send it in both paths okay these are
like controlled not caves in a circuit
so so what you get is actually you get
repetitions and you get X horse when you
look at the tree okay so in the tree you
have you have latest where you have X
ores and you have layers with this
corresponds to repetitions this whole
thing is like a to the her2 the matrix
over Gyptian so there's always in this
case it's always binary for the simplest
version and you should think of this as
maybe a thousand by thousand matrix here
okay now it turns out that and that's
the kind of the miracle of polarization
that independent of you know with high
probability an independent of of what
you're actually you know sending here
there are certain positions which you
can almost always decode okay so you can
decode with high probability and there's
some other positions here which you can
essentially never decode okay so it
completely polarizes to either being
almost certain to be able to code or
almost certain to have a zero knowledge
okay and the other miracle is that
exactly you know if whatever whatever
they did the capacity of this let's
assume the capacitive this channel is a
half then exactly half of these
positions would be
perfect and half of the positions would
be useless and so then the code is very
simple you simply pick these positions
which are which are perfect let's assume
the blue ones he put the information in
there you pick those positions which are
useless you put zeros in there okay and
so now you simply take this bit encode
it that's your code word and now you go
down this this this decoding order as i
said but if it's a useless channel okay
you already know in both sides that's a
zero so you can decode perfectly because
it's already agreed upon and if it's a
perfect channel you can decode by
definition okay so that's kind of how
the code works now what's the
relationship to read miller codes well
it also you know uses this matrix but it
makes a different choice of which of
these positions is pick this information
and which of these positions are what's
called frozen and what is the choice
there well for example let's assume that
all of these things are zero except the
last bit isn't one okay if you go
through it and chase down so the one
will come out here but that one will
also flow here and we'll go down here
and if you chase it down you will see
that if example you set a zero everyone
here and everything else 0 all of these
positions will be a one okay so this
gives you a maximum weight to be n code
word here but for example up here okay I
guess if you chase it down here this
will be a one and I guess that's the
only one okay so there's some position
that gives you a lot of ones and their
son position give you a few ones and
since this is a linear code you know the
the weight and the distance between
quarters that's the same thing so what
do you do for four reed-muller codes is
you simply pick those positions here
that give you code words out here that
have maximum weight okay and that
guarantees that the set of code words if
you're looking at the separation between
two things has maximum separation and it
turns out that this distance between if
you do that and if you pick a rate that
somewhere between zero and one it turns
out that the minimum distance of the
code words implied here is of the order
square root of n okay so that's in
general much better I mean also for
polar cause it's where event but the
constant by definition is is better here
okay so these are quotes get kind of
maximize the weight versus the other
codes are codes that somehow work for
this polarization
okay so if you try it out okay so if you
simply simulate things then it turns out
that actually Rick Miller codes are
significantly better than polar codes we
know that polar codes already achieve
your capacity but the dis speed at which
the achieve capacity in other words the
length that you need in order to have a
certain air probably if you're
transmitting at a certain gap from
capacity is much smaller okay so this is
just a simple example here this is again
a binary erasure channel this is the
error probability and as you go from
left to right you basically start with a
polar code and then you end up with a
reed-muller code there's kind of an
interpolation to go from one the other
one and it turns out that least for this
experiment this is what random codes can
do which is essentially the optimum
thing you can see that Rick metal quotes
are actually very very good okay so the
question is you know if they're so good
perhaps we should actually use them but
before we can even use them we should
know basic things about them and the
first question that we should know about
them is whether they even able to
achieve capacity right looks pretty
clear that they should they look better
than then and then polar quotes but you
know it's not like we actually know and
indeed as I said this was an open
problem in the science institute last
last year when we were here and two
groups started working on it and I'll
tell you just right now you know how
this story unfolds so now we not the
first to ask this question in the 60s
already people had come up and you know
passed this question with a reed-muller
codes achieve capacity and there were
several other references we could find
in the literature but much more lately
you know three people this is emmanuel a
bay this is a vivid Kison and a moosh
pooka have looked at that and they found
a very nice proof that indeed these
codes achieve capacity but you know this
is in a particular regime on kids in the
regime where the rates either go 20 or
21 okay now in computer science this
regime you know can make perfect sense
the applications for codes in which you
know the capacity already you know the
rate itself is not the deciding you know
setting things so it was a very nice
result but let's say if you want to use
codes for communications but you want to
fix a particular rate maybe it's a raid
0.1
the rate 0.9 depending what the channel
is and so what I want to show you now is
that yes indeed they achieve capacity
I'll you know just for the simplest case
the binary erasure channel but it turns
out it's indeed for all rates between
zero and one now you would assume that
you know typically when you look at
codes and you try to do it to prove
anything about you would assume that you
need to know a lot about the details but
I haven't told you you know much about
what this code really is I've told you
know it's it's this matrix you picking
certain rose but I haven't really told
you much about the details of the code
and you would assume that the next thing
you know I have to tell you now a lot
about the structure of the code
properties maybe the weight distribution
other things but it turns out that
actually we need to know almost nothing
about the code ok so there's only a
single property about the code that we
need to know and this property is that
this code has a high degree of symmetry
and I tell you what it is ok and indeed
whatever tell you now has actually
nothing to do with per se reed-muller
codes but simply that the crux of the
matter will be that any code that is
highly symmetric will actually achieve
capacity so symmetry is enough to be a
good coat so there are free ingredients
codes a highly symmetric then I'll tell
you something about that you know
mainstay of theoretical computer sends
about symmetric monotone sets that have
sharp thresholds and something that
actually came out of analysis of of
iterative codes or codes on graphs which
is called the area theorem and exit
functions ok so the first one it's very
easy to dispense with and this is you
know that many other papers but these
papers already in the late 60s by
kissimmee Lynn and Peterson that proof
that these red metal codes are highly
symmetric so let me just tell you what
kind of symmetry that we need so again
this is a very simple example I just
show you graphically let's assume you
take all the codes of the code in this
case it's just length N and I guess
maybe read a half or something like that
and let's assume you put them all as
Rose you know just write the model of
roads so these are zeros and ones two
zeros you consider
so what does it mean for code to be
tracked one transitive okay it means
something very simple it simply means
that no column in here plays any special
rule okay that you can find a
permutation that maps any column to any
other column okay so for example so you
tell me for example that you want to map
column 12 Kong three okay then the game
is that I have to find your permutation
on the index set okay so from from 0 to
8 such that this permutation carries
column 1 to come Three and for the rest
it's completely free okay we don't care
we don't we don't worry about what is
but you have to find me a permutation
and this permutation has to be in such a
way that the set of code words stays
preserved ok so the code has to be
invariant under this permutation now if
you look at these rows it's no longer
exactly the same but that's simply
because the rose stem cells have shifted
to ok so if I simply shift the rows then
you can see indeed that they could have
stayed in variant ok so one transitive
simply means that if i look at the
autumn more efficient group of the
quotes I mean look at the set of
permutations that keep their code
invariant ok then there's at least you
know one transitive you know this it for
every index I I can find an ji can find
that permutation that map's I to J into
this autumn or physical now if you know
what one transitive is then it's also
pretty clear what to transit if is right
so now i'm simply i can simply ask for
two conditions right as long as these
conditions you know can be fulfilled so
for example column one must be mapped to
column free and column let's say eight
must be mapped to column for ok so for
any such pairs you have to find me again
a permutation again that map's these
columns into it and it keeps the code
invariant ok and so all we are saying
now that was already proved in 68 that
Peterson and and it all is that with
Miller quotes among a class of course
not the only quotes are codes that are
two transitive ok and that's the only
property that will actually need to need
for it for these kind of coats to prove
what we want to prove
okay so that's ingredient number one now
again right what we want to show is that
this Court's achieve capacity so it
means you know I remember these curves
that went down these probability of
error occurs and when the length becomes
large this you know should become jumps
and I want this jump to happen at
capacity right so that's that's really
what I need to prove so what we need a
tool is to show that certain curves or
certain functions have sharp thresholds
and so what we use is you know a very
very basic tool basic in the sense that
it's you know very very useful in
theoretical computer science you know
probably physics too and this tool goes
back to to a set of people i guess i
have to picture it will be later on that
the proof that certain functions as you
know the n is the block line for this
day is there as they set or the
dimension of the author function goes to
infinity exhibit sharp fresh hole so let
me just tell you what is this set
setting that i consider here so we are
working on the Hamming cube so 0 1 to
the N and let's take a subset of the
hemming cube-like so some subset of the
of the 0 1 vectors and what it means for
such a said to be monotone it's just you
know I guess in math this is called in
an upper set or an upset it simply means
that i have the natural partial order on
the vectors of 0 1 right in which i
simply component wise compare things and
now i'm saying that omega is monotone
that if an element is is already in the
set right if i have an element in there
then anytime i'm adding extra zeros
extra once i'm flipping is 0 to a 1 so
making it larger in the partial order it
also has to be in here okay so that's
all we're talking about so i have this
is monotone if i have to an Omega and
Omega Prime and this is large in the
partial order and the Omega prime is
already in there that the Omega also has
to be here right so a very natural very
natural
property for set to have okay so that
explains what monotones of example if
you say if you look at this set here if
you're looking at it you know for
example this vector is in here so if I
flip this zero to a one that this must
also be in there and indeed we have this
this element also in here but if i took
out for example the last one here this
it would no longer be monitor right
because it's missing this money okay now
the next thing is i need to explain what
symmetric is because we need monotone
and symmetric sets but that's very easy
because i already explained it for omega
to be symmetric means exactly what I
have described before hand maybe it must
be one transitive ok so again it's just
a set of vectors of length n right and
again I want no column to play any
special role so it simply means that
there must be again a permutation for
every I and J the Mets I to J ok so for
a set to be symmetric simply means it
must be one transitive for example if
the set was cyclic right so if I could
secretly shift it and would stay in
burien then that would be one transit
okay so i have monotone and symmetric
sets if you look at that he here this is
symmetric but for example if you took
this out it will no longer be symmetric
is easy to see just hang out of this
column has a 10 and one that this column
has a 111 so there's no way that I can
map one column to the other one and it
would stay with stay pursuit right okay
so now we have monotone and symmetric
sets so let me now just put you know a
probability on this set so I just put
the standard burn or the product measure
on this on this element so meaning take
any element in here right and simply
assign to it the probability which is
epsilon which is a parameter between 0
and 1 to the weight of this vector here
that's 1 minus epsilon n minus the
weight right so clearly that forms a
probability distribution on the whole on
this whole Hannah cube here and so then
naturally if I have now set i can define
the probability of this set is simply
the sum of the of the vector of the
probabilities of the vectors in here I
to have a notion of of a probability of
this set here Omega okay now what will
this you know the set B for us well it
turns out that this set later on both
before us x
to the set of AirAsia patterns okay so
think of any ratio as a 1 think of Nani
race this is 0 then this here will be
exactly the probability that we get an
AirAsia pattern that falls in this
particular set Omega okay and so this
set will have a have a particular
meaning okay and so now as I said this
goes back you know there many many
versions of this but this choleric book
and began and we using a particular
version of theirs so and what is the
what this diversion says it says that if
you have such you know if you have if
Omega is monotone and symmetric right
and you're simply cladding plotting the
MU of Omega here as a function of the
epsilon right so if you actually so this
is the absolute this probability depend
on epsilon then unless this function is
completely constant for example if you
take omega to be the whole set or you
take omega be empty set right then we'll
be added a zero function or the one
function but if it's not trivial then it
will have a fast jump here okay so the
width of this transition here is of size
1 over log n ok so you have a if n goes
to infinity you simply get a jump of
this function and so this will be
important for us okay so we need you
know before maybe move on so we are not
the first one that use these kind of
ideas there's jeans amor and jean-pierre
dilly who have used these kind of ideas
in coding theory in a very beautiful
paper they chose the following if you
take any linear code and you had a
transmitter with ABC or the BSC and you
look at the block map so the optimum
probability of error under the optimum
decoding then it turns out that this
this probability of you know that Ed
code correctly vs. incorrectly so so one
would mean you everything is incorrect
zero would mean everything is correct
that this probability of error as a
function of the of the channel parameter
here has a fast transition and actually
very fast it's 1 over the square root of
the Hamming distance okay so you pick
any code you know and this has a
particular Hamming distance
okay so what's the maximum that this
hammock distance can be we know that as
a function of n DS Hamming distance can
be a small constant times n okay can be
linear in so this means you know you
might have a transition as fast as 1
over square root of n and that's
essentially as fast as it can be because
just the transitions just the
uncertainty of the channel itself shows
you that that even if the code was
completely optimum you would have it's
moving out door like a smearing out of
this transition of 1 over square root of
n just because of the variations of the
chat okay so if you have your code that
has an optimum Hamming distance then
this is a you know a very very strong
result and we have used nothing about
the code other than its linear and the
fact that it you know has a good Hamming
distance okay so that muscle is a very
beautiful result the only problem is
that you know similar eyes if you look
like for example concentration results
where you can prove that lets say a
function is concentrated also here it
doesn't tell you anything where this
transition actually happened right it
simply tells you that there's a jump but
you know this jump could be here the
jump could be here and has nothing to do
with the rate there's the parameters
that you care about do not enter in here
so the question is we want to kind of
get this kind of result but we want to
have it in such a way that we can
determine where this threshold is and
this threshold better be at capacity
right that's what we want to actually
shoot okay so we need one extra
ingredient here it's something that
actually comes from analysis of
iterative code so and goes as follows so
let me give you first a trivial example
let's assume you have n bits here 1 to N
and let's assume there's a single
relationship in here so you can think of
that the first n minus 1 are freely
chosen and the last one is simply the
XOR okay so this is what's called a
single parity check code so it's the
simplest of all possible codes that you
can think of and let's assume that
you're sending now these bits over a
binary erasure channel with a race /
probably epsilon and you get the
observations here so some of these might
be erased and some of them are what
whatever you know you get whatever you
use
okay so now the Y eyes now are still
whatever you sent but there's an extra
ratio probability so now what would be
the optimum estimator if you wanted to
estimate let's a bit I and it's the
optimum thing here right given that you
have this observation here all right
well let's do the following up to the
optimum estimator but I don't allow you
to look at the pit itself so this still
the I means you can look at the whole
vector except the pit itself okay if the
bid itself is received then there's no
question it's exactly the bit that's the
erasure channel right but you're
interesting question is what is if the
pit itself is not received so this is
the optimum estimator in which you
couldn't look at everything except
debate itself so they optimized tomato
forbid I and you know it's very clear
what they should be well if any of the
other bits are erased then you can't see
anything because it's the XOR of the
other bits but if their generation here
right then this could be equally likely
be 0 and 1 and you don't know anything
but if all of them are not erased then
it's just the Sun right and so that's
the optimum estimator here and so then
what is the probability that that you
cannot determine the bit that it's
erased well it's just 1 minus the
probability that all of the other guys
were actually received right that's very
clear and if you now do a trivial
calculation you integrate out this
function here this probability of error
as a function of the ratio probability
and you plot this curve here you see
that this gives you n minus 1 over N but
this is 1 minus 1 over N but that's
exactly the rate of the code ok so now
this is a trivial example but it turns
out that this example is you know
generalizes so no matter what code I
give you if I'm plotting the probability
of the average probability of error
determine the I've bit looking at
everything except the I've bit and
average it out over all the components
of the code ok again it's not very hard
to see and applauding this curve and I'm
integrating this out that this is always
equal to the rate of the code ok so this
is an embarrassed of the code as you
have invariants in physics right so
that's a it's a nice quantity it is
exactly this property that we will use
and you know you saw flashing the proof
it's not very difficult to to see why
this is true
okay so this is called ok this is the
proof doesn't matter now I'm not going
to go for the proof but it's just a few
lengths ok it least for the erasure
channel it's it's fairly simple for
general channels it's it's it's quite a
little bit more complicated but it
doesn't matter right now ok so if you
believe that first of all this goes back
to you know people that first looked at
it is Steven tempering Garrett crema
Alexi Ashe came in this was for the
binary channel input a channel channel
this was some joint work with arias
actually Andrea okay so this is true for
the BC but it's also for the proper
quantity which is not exactly the 1i
short but for some proper generation is
also true for channel chance okay so now
we have all the ingredients that we
actually need okay so we want to put
things together so again let's remind
ourselves codes are highly symmetric
monotone symmetric sets have sharp
thresholds okay and we have this funny
invariant of a code which is called the
area film okay so whatever curfew you
know you plot this curve this curve scan
so did you know you have to think of the
air film that there's not good or bad
codes they simply cultures that have
different characteristics as a function
of the channel okay so some of them have
steep one some of them have flat ones
but if you look at the kind of the total
gain that they give you over the set of
the whole channel it's always the same
okay it's just they some of them are
better at some values than other ones so
there's no codes at this sit for the
same rate there in some you know that
you cannot compare them that if you want
to compare with the whole range okay so
let's put things together now okay so
it's kind of clear what I want to do
right I want to apply now d you know I
want to apply now the sharp fresh of
results to these particular exit
functions right I'm going to show that
there's a sharp threshold and then I
want to use the area film to determine
what is threshold actually is okay so
let's let's do this so um so we have
this set so so we have now a particular
code enmities brit milah codes okay and
now it turns out that this code since it
calls a linear and the binary erasure
channel is what's called symmetric which
simply means there's no preference
between 0 and 1 it's completely
symmetric in here it doesn't matter what
actually we sent ok so its independent
the analysis we can do assuming in any
particular code word for sending some
particular
we will sue assume is that the 0 code
word percent and so the only thing that
will see is actually the pattern is at a
zero Zora ratios okay so all we look at
that and instead of any ratio i'm going
to right now one okay so 0 means it's
correctly received a ratio means it's
incorrectly received and so what I'm
going to look at this now for this case
is I'm going to look exactly at this
decoding function here and I'm asked
when is it you know incorrectly done and
I'm going to look at this particular
function and so the what will happen is
that if i'm looking now my said omega I
here then this is simply the set of all
those Oratia patterns that cause trouble
okay so what I do is this I have the
code I now you know send the code right
here and there will be particular Oratia
patterns that I have and I'm going to
look for each Oratia pattern where I can
decode the ice pick or not if I can
decode it it's good if not I'm going to
put it in the set Omega I ok and since
my decoder is defined that I'm not
looking at the I speed itself they said
it's only already mentioned you know n
minus 1 ok I'm not looking at the I flip
itself so this is a set and so you know
I let me just skip it but it you know
it's very clear so what do we want to
not do with this set ok we want to prove
that it fulfills these conditions that
we have for the decoder right we want to
show late Smollett on that symmetric
right and then we can apply our our
analysis so what is the characterization
of this set while a pattern and a ratio
pattern Omega will be in this set if and
only if the following is true so let's
assume this is my this is my pattern of
oratius so this was this could this
position was fine this position was
erased erased fine this one we don't
looking at because the I've position etc
so this one will be in capital Omega if
and only the following is true the
existing code word C that is dominated
by this ratio pattern meaning whenever
have a 1 there must be a one on top ok
and it must have a one at the position I
ok now why does this cause trouble
because if I have this this is all I see
right he's are the ratios I don't what I
see will be this pattern here right and
because I see only this pattern I cannot
distinguish between the old zero pattern
and the pattern that actually has one of
these positions of the code word right
and so
since the code is linear what this will
mean is that no matter how many code
words I have that have let's say a 08
position either they're compatible with
various deceived information I have
exactly the same number of codes in
there that haven't won in this position
and compatible with the received
information you know since everything is
uniform they all have the same
probability and if I'm looking at the
optimum estimator you know it's it's
simply a type okay so I don't know which
of the two it was it equally likely to
be a zero and one okay so this is the
characterization and so now just note
the following since we define this set
to be the set of pet of petty ratio
patterns if I'm not taking this
probability that i defined beforehand
right that's exactly what the channel
does right it's on each bit flips or not
flips with probably epsilon 1 minus
epsilon then this function here on the
set right it's exactly my probability
that i cannot decode right and so I can
you know this is exactly this function
here that is my probability of error
okay that I cannot decode the earth bit
and if I average this overall the
position that simply will give me some
average curve okay so now we want to
show that it's monotone it's two
transitive and and so let's let me you
know we want to just show that these
properties that true so let's just check
the first property it's monotone is very
clear right if I have any racial pattern
in which I cannot determine the I've bit
if I'm adding an extra narration in here
right so I'm still hiding one extra one
then clearly this cannot help right you
know you can see the slightly more
formally if for this ratio pattern never
ever have already a code word that is
covered by those things if I now turn
for example this bit also in addition to
be a one right then clearly this still
covers it right so clearly it's monitor
ok so that's that's easy um what about
you know I want they set Omega I to be
one transitive remember it should have
should be symmetric so it has to be one
transitive so what about this one here
also not difficult remember the code was
to transitive and I claim that that
implies transitivity why do I need the
code to be to transitive and not just
transitive because there's one position
that are fixed and this when i'm looking
for a permutation this presentation is
to carry position I the precision I and
then
they'll have is my second degree of
freedom that carries it here Wright's 02
transitive the code gives me that one
transitivity of the set oh my gosh okay
and then the last one tells me that that
actually we have now always these
positions you know when / see sets omega
i but because of the transitivity code
again all these sets I actually again
the same okay there's just again
permutations of each other so that's
what I just called it's independent of
the position I ok so this means if I put
all these things together if I'm
plotting this function here which is you
know a chai is now the same for each of
them because these are all the same set
so it's just the sum itself then if I'm
looking at that where they put
everything together then this shows that
this function here by freak good and
collide must actually have a sharp
threshold with 1 over log N and so
that's fine but now if I'm using finally
the area theorem right this tells me
that this thing here must be the rate of
the code but it's a zr1 function here so
it means that this position must be
exactly 1 minus aren't that's exactly
capacity ok so this shows that indeed
these codes in the limited chief
capacity so just to wrap up there you
know historically there are several ways
of proving their coats of heat capacity
right for random codes typically look at
weight distribution a bit fulfills it
for calls and graphs you look at as we
said things evolution or in then you
carefully design graphs and do the graph
structure for polar codes that's kind of
falls on the chain rule of mutual
information and what I'm saying here is
that if you look at structured codes if
they have enough structure name is
symmetry in here then just symmetry
itself guarantees that achieve class
maybe it's just some extensions you know
there are many other classes of codes
that have this property and they're
listed here I talked about right now the
bit error probably you can also deal
with the block error probability by
either using a slightly stricter form of
this of this monotone function theorem
or by looking at weight distributions
you can look at source coding folds like
this and towards a dog being involved
but my courses have involved you can
look at quantum version
or you know some even carried on beyond
like just to transitivity and use the
same same kind of ideas good so now
that's the end of wednesday chest maybe
towards what would be really nice now is
to an extent is for general channels
there's still some bottlenecks which we
don't know how to solve yet i think the
same proof should work but we don't know
exactly how and then all this is still
just the first step you know this simply
proves that these quotes are very good
but we still need and hopefully you know
some relationships to polar course will
help there is to show that indeed you
can also decode them efficiently right
it's one thing to say that this was a
very good it's another one to find an
efficient algorithm say linear or at
least maybe maybe quadratic or something
or and log and that can actually do that
is cooling up to this limit good and let
stand for me thank you very much all
right
good / hire a question so okay when I
started to learn about all this from
your tree few years ago I remember
because the big deal was to try to
achieve capacity and now it seemed that
there is a profusion of cottage in
capacity pull a console oh and right but
they're not all the same in you know it
the same in the limit but if you look at
what codes actually use you want to have
it short length right so for example
polar codes are beautiful because
they're nice properties all provable but
if you look at the block length it's
roughly the square of what you should be
able to you know what you should be able
to do okay so if you look at the block
length you transmit a certain gap to
capacity to fix error probably and you
look at what block length is required
it's roughly square of what optimal you
should be able to achieve it so finite
length scale so the hope is that
actually drill moco Radmila codes might
actually have the optimum pilot legs
killing so if you could actually get an
algorithm that works this would make a
big difference though
shorter blocks mean that the ramp up is
in fact a slow club I remember from
studying finite size scaling of phase
transitions that there's a good deal of
theory one can go to to understand how
that wrapping of the purse are you
starting to look at that so we looked
for all other codes we looked exactly at
that and that's where for example for
polar quotes it comes that that the the
block length you need if you re
reformulate it is roughly so you need
roughly n squared of the optimum block
length that you would need if you have
you know for the best codes that exists
exactly for this finite length scaling
so if you're looking at for a certain
you fix the probability of error and
you're transmitting at a certain gap
from capacitor way and you're looking at
how these curves approach the you know
this gap okay then you see that the
block length is roughly n squared okay
and oh there's a critical exponent there
about yes yes that's exactly have suits
it's the standard scaling that you see
we have done this also for LDPC and
other codes there turns out that you
have the best exponent but it doesn't
scale to the actually capacity but it
scares to some you know whatever you
know whatever debt limit is which is in
general not capacity so there's still
things you can you can improve and and
the hope is that actually for this Rick
Miller codes but it's not like we know
how to do this that the exponent matter
should be optimum and that the limit you
know the where the phase transition
happens is also often
all right good sign stuff let me go
again